we all remember Parks and Recreation
season two Leslie was trying to fix the
pit Andy and April began their
triumphant weirdo love story Chris
Traeger and Ben Wyatt joined the merry
band of civil servants but do you
remember mark brendanawicz Paul
Schneider played mark the Pawnee Indiana
city planner who was relatively central
character on parks and recreations first
season and who had a scrapped romance
subplot with Amy Poehler's Leslie Knope
in the second season marks purpose began
to flounder despite a second and
ultimately crumbled romance with rashida
Jones 'as and Perkins
during the Parks and Rec season two
finale mark announced he was leaving
city government for a job with a private
sector construction company you know
they offered me a buyout and I took it
and so now I work for norton
construction which earned him a new
nickname from Leslie Mark brand an
acquits
and he was never heard from again Chris
and Ben's entrance into Parks and
Recreation as guest characters on season
two proved to be the perfect gift in
disguise to slip marks departure past
everyone with few questions asked
looking back there are some mysteries
left unsolved why hath Mark leave at all
and why did Paul Schneider exit Parks
and Recreation and never return in short
Paul Schneider left Parks and Recreation
because he felt sidelined several years
after the fact the actor opened up about
his parks departure in an interview with
screen crush revealing that he felt he'd
been at a creative crossroads with the
series writers after mark's character
was altered from the first season the
early episodes of Parks and Rec are
rougher and feature more tension to
stayin between the characters just like
its predecessor the office mark
brendanawicz his character is a relic of
that previous style and he was
reportedly an even less likable
character and earlier versions of Parks
and Recreation a shift in emotional
perspective came about as the series
continued on and while it works out well
for many principal characters it didn't
for mark Schneider said of leaving Parks
and Rec that experience was very strange
for me
you know I signed up for a specific
character that was changed in midseason
and it became a character with a lot
less do and all of a sudden I was kind
of confused and kind of having a lot
less to do
the time news of Schneider's Parks and
Recreation exit went public series
co-creator Michael Shure teased that the
actor would be back for future episodes
he said in March 2010 the goal in the
aim is to have him come back as soon as
his schedule permits and as soon as the
arts were writing call Foy we very much
want him back and he has told us he very
much wants to come back in the future it
really is one of those mutually
beneficial situations and we're hoping
we can have him back in season three
Snyder revealed in April 2014 that he
quote had never been contacted about
returning and he wasn't interested in
doing so at the same time Snyder was
also sympathetic that Parks and
Recreation didn't exactly know what it
was doing at the outset and was quote
very happy for the experience to be
involved but didn't feel any desire to
return to a world that he didn't know
anything about once the series actually
did find its footing the first season of
Parks and Recreation opened to so so
critical response and while the second
season was received better critically
that wasn't reflected in the ratings
Parks and Recreation was more akin to
the little sitcom that could then the
iconic series it is today if we were
Paul Schneider circa 2009 during season
two's production we might actually
anticipate that Parks and Recreation
itself not just Mark Fran danowitz the
character wouldn't have much staying
power might as well get out while you
can write many shows that get to a
second season despite being on the
cancellation bubble don't ever see a
third season and there's a chance that
Schneider felt Parks and Rec wouldn't
last much longer waiting it out probably
would have been the wiser bet in the
long run but Schneider has enjoyed
plenty of work in the years since
leaving Parks and Recreation though none
of it has achieved the same Fame and
cultural status as the noun beloved
sitcom and it seems he's perfectly happy
with that I'm sorry I called you mark
brendan acquits don't ever apologize to
me check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
you
[Music]